[Musique]
non
bonsoir ravi de vous retrouver pour
audition publique c'est notre émission
tous les lundis soirs en direct sur
public sénat lcp assemblée nationale et
le figaro live on est en direct à la
fois pour lancer le débat faire le point
sur les enjeux du moment mieux expliquer
aussi ce qui se passe les réformes ça
bouge beaucoup
les enjeux d'une minutie plat l'on veut
en parler aussi parce que ça se prépare
beaucoup dans les états majors des
partis politiques notamment à droite est
notre invité ce soir et guillaume
pelletier bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
député du loir-et-cher vice président
des républicains numéro 2 donc de
christian jacob si je le fais en simple
au cours de cette émission vous allez
est interrogé par mes consoeurs des
chaînes parlementaires qui vont nous
rejoindre tout à l'heure un député et
une sénatrice qui auront des questions
précises à vous poser aussi parce qu'ils
sont au coeur de la machine
parlementaire si on peut parler comme ça
et puis pour conclure on accueillera
yves thréard du figaro et son regard
aiguisé sur les enjeux politiques
et puis sans oublier les questions que
les téléspectateurs peuvent nous faire
parvenir via le figaro live qui sont
relayés ici et que j'essaierai de vous
relayer en direct autant que possible
ma première question que je vais vous
poser concerne la privatisation
d'aéroports de paris
parce que vous aviez pris position
contre la privatisation adp la pétition
pour l'organisation d'un référendum
d'initiative partagée est à peu près à 1
million de signatures il en faut quatre
millions 7
c'est pas évident les 4 millions 7 est
ce que vous considérez que d'ores et
déjà un cap a été franchi et que
gouvernement doit en tenir compte et
comment oui bien évidemment
d'abord plusieurs choses que c'est un
sujet tellement complexes et sur la sur
les murs oui mais vous parlez comme un
peu des privatisations qu'elle est quel
est notre rapport à la privatisation
nous sommes plutôt favorable a dit
préviennent isation mais pas tout le
temps et pas sur tous les sujets et
certainement pas lorsque le gouvernement
à court de moyens financiers va en
quelque sorte les bijoux de famille ça
c'était notre position nous avons avec
un grand nombre de collègues
parlementaires demandait au gouvernement
et avec question de la coop de revoir sa
copie cette copie elle mérite d'être
totalement refondée puisque sur les
questions budgétaires sur les questions
de sécurité aéroportuaire et plus
globalement de souveraineté nationale
nous avons des questions comme nos
compatriotes et un million de français
qui se mobilisent et qui demande au
président de la république comme au
gouvernement de remettre ce dossier sur
la table ce me semble logique et
j'espère que le gouvernement va nous
entendre et nous l'avons dit
remettez le dossier
il est très important pour qu'on puisse
avoir tous les ans je comprendre tous
les problèmes et que le gouvernement
nous apporte des réponses concrètes
guillaume pelletier on va accueillir
maintenant thème traduit de public sénat
et brigitte boucher de la chaîne
parlementaire assemblée nationale
[Musique]
on va commencer par puisque nous sommes
sur les chaînes parlementaires et que
public sénat et partenaires notamment le
congrès des maires
et oui le congrès de l'association des
maires de france qui est débute cette
semaine à concrètes ou emmanuel macron
sera présent demain l'année dernière il
n'y était pas selon les échos il va
appeler à une union sacrée à jouer la
carte du contact direct avec les élus
est ce que vous vous en réjouissez il
était temps et j'espère qu'il
s'appliquera d'abord ce mot d'ordre
juste d'union a lui même lui qui incarne
depuis le début de son mandat un
président de division de fragmentation
des territoires tant il a abîmé le
rapport entre l'état et les
collectivités
avant oui mais je trouve que sa prise de
conscience et est tardive d'une part et
j'espère que demain il ne jouera pas au
marchand de sable ou d'illusions et
qu'il sera en capacité de faire des
propositions très concrètes aux grandes
urgences que nous vivons sur la santé
sur la mobilité ou sur le financement
des communes rurales des mesures très
concrètes vous pouvez aller plus loin ce
que vous pouvez nous préciser vous dire
ce que vous vous attendez une mesure
précise pas par exemple la première
préoccupation dans nos territoires
confirmé d'ailleurs à l'occasion du
grand débat que vous évoquez à l'instant
c'est le rapport à la santé à la
médecine de proximité vous savez que
dans nos territoires nous n'avons plus
accès à des médecins généralistes et
bien j'espère que ce sujet devait être
abordé nous avons des propositions
concrètes j'en fais deux ce soir et ce
qui va oser avancer sur le cumul emploi
retraite pour tous nos médecins qui ont
qui sont à la retraite aujourd'hui et
qui veulent servir dans les territoires
mais qui ne le peuvent pas parce que
leurs cotisations retraite ne leur
servent pas donc il n'y a pas d'intérêt
pour eux aujourd'hui à asservir les
territoires ruraux
deuxièmement j'ai même un peu plus loin
avec quelques dizaines de collègues
parlementaires j'ai déposé un texte de
loi dont je parle dans mon livre milieu
de cordée qui visent à réguler la
liberté d'un
la scion des jeunes médecins pendant
deux années comme l'ont fait les
allemands et les québécois parce que
l'enjeu est tel dans nos territoires on
ne peut plus laisser la souffrance de
nos quatre trios concrètes
guillaume pelletier nous sommes à
quelques mois des municipales et on le
voit sur un sondage seulement moins d'un
maire sur deux veut se représenter
est-ce que vous ressentez bien cette
désaffection chez l air et comment vous
l'expliquez vous alors moi je vois dans
mon département de loir et cher janvier
j étais tout à l'heure et tout au long
des derniers jours j'ai rencontré
évidemment beaucoup de maires qui sont à
la fois en pré campagne municipale et
qui sont épuisés par un deux ou trois
mandats c'est à dire la lourdeur de la
tâche l'impression d'être les
sentinelles de la république mais
abandonnés par la république elle même
et je crois que le président république
à la demande très justifié de françois
baroin le président des maires de france
et je me réjouis qu'il ait rejoint notre
équipe dirigeante des républicains doit
entendre cette colère et cette
désespérance on a besoin d' annonces
concrètes pour redonner de l'oxygène et
de l' enthousiasme sans nos communes
rurales sans nos mères des territoires
mais aussi des villes moyennes et des
métropoles de province
la république ne serait pas aussi solide
qu'elle est aujourd'hui donc on a besoin
d'eux il ya un projet de loi sur le
statut de l'élu qui a été discuté au
sénat qui arrive à l'assemblée
aujourd'hui même ce projet jouais pas si
consensuel qu'on aurait pu le croire
finalement au début
est ce que pour la droite c'est une
façon aussi de faire de la politique
d'imposer un rapport de force avant les
municipales
je vais prendre un exemple de du projet
que vous évoquez on en parlait avec
gérard larcher bruno retailleau qui sans
jacob encore récemment on nous annonce
il ya quelques mois un vrai statut de
l'élu
on ne peut vous voulez qu'on s'en
réjouir ça fait des années et des années
que nous demandions
et puis à force d avance et on se rend
compte que la question par exemple des
indemnités très faible des maires des
communes rurales vont être soumises à
l'approbation du conseil municipal pris
sur les fonds propres des communes au
fond rendre cette réforme va rendre
prisonnier les maires les plus
volontaires
on demandait une fois de plus il est
quand même partir manque au casque
lorsqu'il est ce que ce soit l'état qui
fixe le tarif
bien sûr il est quand même partir mon
cocasse de voir l'état autoritaire
lorsqu'il s'agit de se désengager et
faussement intéressés ou en tout cas
très distant lorsqu'il s'agit
d'accompagner les maires et les tarifs
des mains mais c'était le cas jusqu'à
maintenant c'est ce gars là revenir à
sion des strates et vous savez une les
maires des communes de moins de 1000
2000 ou 3000 habitants ce sont des
hommes et des femmes qui consacrent
toute leur journée et leurs nuits tout
leur semaine au service ce strict de
leurs concitoyens une indemnisation de
mer pour un maire rochon passionnant
c'est parce que vous êtes aujourd'hui
ces quelques centaines d'euros
mais ce serait quoi alors moi je
considère qu'à maire d'une commune
rurale qui consacre l'essentiel de son
temps à ses concitoyens le niveau autour
de 2000 euros me semblerait pas absurde
vous pouvez pas imaginer l'engagement
aujourd'hui le maire dans une commune
c'est le gendarme d'autres fois c'est
l'instituteur d'autres fois c'est ce
sont les services sociaux d'autres fois
on a besoin de soutenir et d'encourager
à l'engagement municipal
il sera bien accueilli quand même
emmanuel macron congrès des maires de
france demain les maires sont des élus
reddick distance sur la mode est sifflé
je ne souhaite pas de tensions on ne
choisit jamais y en a deux options mais
il peut y en avoir par pourquoi parce
que le président la république et son
gouvernement à chaque fois qu'une
promesse est annoncée elle n'est pas
tenue et donc il ya une colère immense
dans notre pays à propos de colère on va
parler du contexte social un an du
mouvement du gilet jaune beaucoup moins
nombreux dans les rues samedi qu'il ya
un an mais ils sont toujours là
un an après oui il y a un petit peu deux
visions de ce mouvement dit gilet jaune
du côté de l'exécutif on estime que le
mouvement est aujourd'hui complètement
gangréné par les ultras et c'est pour ça
qu'il ya de la violence et de l'autre
côté il ya ceux qui pensent que c'est la
stratégie policière qui est mis en place
qui fait que les manifestations
dégénèrent ça c'est plutôt que le côté
mélenchon vous où vous trouvez vous au
milieu des français
tout ça ce sont des analyses je sais que
ce ne sont pas les vôtres à vous relayez
très politicienne quelle est la réalité
la violence
il y a d'un côté une infime minorité
violente qui n'a rien à voir avec les
jets les jaunes chacun le sait ce sont
des minorités
ces derniers mois d'extrême gauche qui
utilisent ces événements pour briser été
échangé durant le black bloc soit
d'accord des forces de police et de
sécurité
donc ça ne disent pas qu'elles sont ce
sont quelques centaines voire quelques
milliers d'individus
et d'ailleurs nous sommes du côté des
forces de sécurité et de l'ordre et nous
demandons au gouvernement d'être d'une
fermeté implacable à l'égard de ces
individus fait légalement il fait bien
son travail le préfet de police de paris
bah quand on voit les propos
particulièrement provocateur ce week-end
lorsqu'il utilise ce mot très maladroit
pour un préfet de la république de dire
je ne suis pas de votre camp ni veste
gilet jaune enfin un préfet de la
république
il est sinon de tous les camps en tout
cas au dessus des ouled alors non entre
temps cette polémique mais j'espère
qu'il va lui une science il devrait au
moins s'excuser parce qu'un préfet de la
république si on veut croire en la
république on a besoin d'avoir des
hommes qui représente la fonction
républicaine et qui toi d'autres
estiment que je reviens de rappeler
alors oui je reviens au fond du problème
qu'est ce que nous sommes en train de
vivre nous fait nous vivons d'ailleurs
beaucoup le reconnaissent aujourd'hui
j'entends des parrains du nouveau
concert natacha polony qui le disaient
nous vivons ou encore françois lenglet
dans un livre remarquable la fin du
cycle néolibérale qui conduit
aujourd'hui parce que les français comme
les européens se sentent tellement
déposséder sur le plan social économique
d'une part mais aussi très inquiet sur
le plan d'une fracture civique et
communautariste très angoissante se
sentent dépossédés de la maîtrise de
leur destin et à la fin de ce cycle au
néo libérale nous les républicains nous
apportons une réponse nous inventons
deux réponses principal avec christian
jacob
d'abord nous sommes le parti du travail
de la récompense du travail pas le parti
de la finance incarné par monsieur
macron certainement pas le parti de
l'assistanat le parti qui récompense
aussi le travail où je suis au travail
et 2 et moi je lui permettais général
jeu si vous permettez
j'y reviens le parti de la laïcité ne
croyons pas que dans la colère des gilet
jaune
il n'y avait que les questions
économiques et sociales il y a
un double enseignement une colère
sociale
mêlée à l'inquiétude d'une fracture
civique et à ses deux fractures
nous apportons ces deux réponses le
parti du travail et le parti la laïcité
pourtant vous vous plaidé pour une
hausse générale des salaires c'est le
parti du travail ça de monter les
salaires incontestablement victor hugo
le disais il y à déjà bien longtemps
nicolas sarkozy l'a incarné avec les
heures supplémentaires défiscalisées le
général de gaulle avec la fragmentation
l'intéressement
moi je propose j'apporte cette
contribution grand débat à droite qui se
conclura en juillet prochain par un
congrès des idées je propose une réforme
révolutionnaire en trois temps est à
égalité
la suppression des cotisations
patronales pour toutes les entreprises
pour créer un choc de compétitivité
baisser le coût du travail dans notre
pays la deuxième manche deuxième chose
la suppression de toutes les cotisations
salariales qui pèse sur les salaires
pour permettre à chaque français
je dis bien à chaque français de voir
son revenu brut fonctionnaires salariés
ou retraités devenir le revenu net
hausse de 20% tous a financé par une
cotisation sociale de 2%
surtout les 30 toutes les transactions
financières et les paiements
électroniques
exemple quand vous allez faire un plein
de courses à 50 euros
ça voudrait 51 euros mais pour un
français qui gagne aujourd'hui 1700
euros nets
son salaire passerait à 2200 euros net
chaque mois c'est une brise de finale
c'est tous ces français qui cotisent
s'éteint c'est un changement radical
puisque nous permettons aux pme de
gagner le combat de la compétitivité
nous permettons français d'augmenter le
pouvoir d'achat parce que les français
n'en peuvent plus de ne plus voir
d'écart entre les revenus du travail et
les revenus de la crise quand c'est le
grand sujet du jour est ce que vous êtes
favorable à une grande conférence
sociale c'est la demande du centrisme
pour pouvoir sortir et bien de cette
crise du gilet jaune
je crois que le modem qui a fait cette
proposition
ont-ils lu mon livre ont ils vu les
prises de position de ma famille
politique de ces dernières semaines je
pense à valérie pécresse et rachida dati
dans la campagne municipale à paris je
pense à xavier bertrand qui a fait
sienne ces propositions aussi récemment
oui il ya urgence à ce que le
gouvernement prenne en compte la
souffrance sociale la souffrance sociale
elle repose essentiellement dans notre
pays sur la colère pour les retraités
les fonctionnaires et les travailleurs
comme les entrepreneurs de voir que ceux
qui travaillent
ne sont pas récompensés à la fin du mois
tant les charges et les impôts sont un
parc on parlait de gilet jaune une
réaction là de sofia sur le figaro les
gilet jaune c'est aussi le bilan des
élus de gauche et de droite au pouvoir
depuis des années elle renvoie dos à dos
non mais la raison vous et moi je dois
bien vous assumez mais j'ai un peu plus
de 40 ans c'est toute l'histoire que je
raconte dans mon livre il ya 40 ans
l'année de ma naissance
il n'y avait pas de dette et pas de
déficit et pas de chômage pourquoi j'ai
décidé de m'engager en politique c'est
pour être le porte parole de tous ces
milieux de cordes et de toutes ses
classes moyennes jeunes apprentis
retraités agriculteurs fonctionnaires
travailleurs qui ne sont jamais
représentés
le président de république a décidé il a
dit lui-même d'être le président des
premiers de cordée de ceux pour lesquels
tout va bien très bien on a besoin de
premiers de cordée
mais 70% des français dans notre pays
les milieux de cordes et non pas de
représentant et le parti des
républicains est en train de devenir le
représentant de ces français des classes
perenco stratégie et jaune
en tout cas il répondra à la colère
légitime des français on va parler d'un
autre souci actuellement pour les
français et d'une autre grande réforme
pour le gouvernement ce sont les
retraites beau dit oui une grève est
annoncée le 5 décembre à la ratp à la
sncf
est ce que vous vous croyez un blocage
général du pays et à une convergence des
luttes on voit qu'il ya plusieurs foyers
de contestation en ce moment d'abord je
crois au droit de grève mais je récuse
le droit de bloquer ce n'est pas tout à
fait la même chose et il faut que nos
compatriotes qui ont l'intention d'aller
travailler puissent le faire en toute
liberté
je crains que ça ne soit pas le cas pour
autant derrière la question que vous
posez se pose effectivement l'enjeu
crucial des retraites
notre famille politique ces dernières
années je pense à nicolas sarkozy je
pense à jacques chirac ont entamé des
réformes courageuses suffisante
suffisante à l'époque c'était il ya 10
ou 15 ans il nous faut aujourd'hui
évidemment les appros fonctionnalités
que des rustines si on considère le
déficit de 2025 8 à 10 7 millisecondes
dit le corps si on est traître éléments
stationné ça a permis pour une décennie
à chaque fois de sauver de maintenir le
système de rodez que ça pas été des
rustines comme dit non enfin ça d une
réforme des retraites sur un smartphone
non mais sur 50 ont pris une gifle
les cinq ans ce sont des rustines vous
me permettez le gouvernement qui entame
une réforme pour dix ans comme le firent
jacques chirac et nicolas sarkozy pour
maintenir le pouvoir d'achat des
retraités c'est une réforme qui a marché
il nous faut une nouvelle réforme en
disant la vérité aux français nous
vivons plus longtemps
il nous faut donc travailler plus
longtemps sauf qu emmanuel macron non
aux français de deux manières il dit je
réforme maintenant et on apprend par la
bouche de monsieur delevoye
c'est une réforme qui prendra effet dans
40 ans c'est la fameuse soirée du grand
exactement en fin de compte
au fond tout le monde peut faire ce
genre de réforme faut faire une retraite
comme ce que proposait foncier pendant
la campagne présidentielle
aller jusqu'à 65 ans pour partir à la
retraite
non c'est ce que nous nous proposons une
réforme des retraites
maintenant la suppression de tous les
régimes spéciaux l'égalité public privé
du système de retraite et dire la vérité
aux français
il faut pour sauver le régime selon le
conseil d'orientation des retraites
43 ans en moyenne de cotisation et bien
moi je pense que chaque français doit
pouvoir partir à la retraite à l'âge de
son choix
liberté mais avec une retraite modulée
c'est à dire que vous avez commencé tôt
à travailler admettons à 18 ans vous
devez pouvoir partir à 61 ans et même
avant mais avec une retraite moindre
ou si vous êtes encore suffisamment
forme un peu plus tard avec une retraite
majorée c'est à dire que celle inverse
de la préforme de d'emmanuel macro
emmanuel macron dit c'est maintenant en
fin de compte ce sera dans 40 ans et dit
on ne touche pas à l'âge légal - je
considère que l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite
il a plus aucun sens ce qui a du sens
c'est l'âge de liquidation de la
retraite à taux plein que chaque
français connaît au bout 43 ans voilà
chaque français connaîtra précisément sa
retraite à taux plein il pourra partir
avant ou après mais il saura jusqu'à
quand il faut travailler pour avoir ce
genre de tracas et les votre position
par rapport à la grève du 5 décembre
vis-à-vis des retraites est ce que c'est
quand même justifiée puisque après tout
vous êtes pas du tout d'accord avec la
retraite des manuels à la réforme des
manuels macron si c'est une grève
ponctuelles pour demander au
gouvernement d'entendre les français
pourquoi pas quand je vois ce qui est en
train de se
préparée je sens avec ce que vous
appeliez la convergence des luttes
une volonté une volonté de bloquer notre
pays
bloquer notre pays c'est inacceptable
parce que ceux qui sont pénalisés ce
sont toujours les mêmes c'est à dire les
entrepreneurs les travailleurs les
classmoyins premier et amis mesure n'a
quant à lui le 5 décembre si vous voulez
bien sûr puis pourriez aller dans la rue
vous à cette occasion non parce que mon
rôle de parlementaire
c'est d'essayer d'aiguillés le
gouvernement pour lui faire ouvrir les
yeux et avec eric woerth avec christian
jacob de faire des contre-propositions
nous avons un projet de contre-projet la
réforme c'est ce que vous demandez de la
retirer et de présenter une nouvelle
réforme aux français fondé sur trois
piliers l'égalité suppression des
régimes spéciaux
la justice publique privée et la liberté
pour chaque français de partir à l'âge
de son choix avec une retraite à taux
plein on va parler maintenant la
situation dans les hôpitaux parce qu'il
y à un mouvement dans les hôpitaux de
grève depuis bientôt neuf mois et des
mesures sont attendues tam dans les
jours qui viennent normalement
effectivement de mercredi d'un film bat
annoncé de grandes mesures pour
l'hôpital vous qu'est ce que vous
attendez de lui quelle mesure vous
voulez vous pour l'hôpital au moins deux
lunes évoqué chez vous je crois ce matin
par françois baroin à juste titre que
l'état montre sa considération pour les
hôpitaux dans notre pays et les
remarquables personnel hospitalier qui
travaillent par une reprise de la dette
30 milliards d'euros pour envoyer un
signal
oui pour envoyer un signal très fort à
l'ensemble de nos compatriotes l'hôpital
devient l'une des grandes priorités dans
notre pays ainsi que les questions de
santé
ça c'est là la part positive il faut des
efforts et moi ce que je souhaite c'est
que le gouvernement prenne conscience
d'un grand enjeu qui est évoqué par
didier migaud dans la cour des comptes
que j'évoque dans mon livre milieu de
cordée vous savez combien coûte chaque
année à la france
la désertification médicale le fait que
nous n'ayons pas accès à des médecins
généralistes 3 milliards d'euros 3
milliards d'euros par an deuxième
conséquence
comme nous n'avons pas de médecin
général et dans nos territoires que font
nos concitoyens ils se rendent aux
urgences qui sont engorgés et par
conséquent qui déséquilibre le système
si edouard philippe est en capacité
d'annoncer mercredi je crois mais une
reprise de la dette d'une part pour
envoyer un signal fort à nos
compatriotes
et deuxièmement une réorganisation
complète dans nos territoires de la
médecine de ville avec une meilleure
rémunération des médecins généralistes
une une incitation très forte pour tous
nos jeunes médecins prochaine loi il ya
eu ma santé 2022 qui est censé lui
médical sauf que ça va prendre du temps
épuisé mais pour créer ces maisons de
legrand preuve de ce projet il propose
des maisons
j'en ai créé une quand j'étais maire de
ma de ma commune aujourd'hui
heureusement elle est pleine mais la
plupart des maisons de santé sont vides
parce que les médecins qui sortent de
l'école sont se met systématiquement aux
au même endroit et donc dans nos
territoires c'est le désert médical
absolue la proposition que je fais c'est
une liberté réguler pendant deux ans et
je peux vous assurer comme au québec
comme en allemagne ça changerait
radicalement le système va continuer à
parler sentais un peu parce que brigitte
avait une question à propos de l'alcool
et oui parce que didier guillaume la
ministre de l'agriculture s'est prononcé
ce week-end pour un taux d'alcool 0
roule au volant
est ce que vous vous approuver cette
cette idée fait des propos toujours un
peu simpliste et démagogique il me
semble il me semble et c'est je le dis
avec beaucoup d'esprit de responsabilité
un verre de vin ça fait du mal à
quelqu'un
non mais en voulant la 01 rail d'alcool
verre de vin qu'est-ce que ça qu'est ce
qu'il ya derrière sa phrase qu'est ce
qu'il ya derrière ça fera vous imaginez
le mépris à l'égard de tous les
viticulteurs de tous les agriculteurs de
notre pays
culture ce lieu quand on les écoute
quand on écoute les représentants
viticole et agricole aujourd'hui ils ont
assez peu apprécié sa sortie qui sentent
le mans assez peu équilibrée ce que nous
disons c'est qu'il nous faut être
intraitable sur la question de la
sécurité routière
évidemment intraitable mais que
franchement mais que franchement la
question d'un verre de vin c'est
certainement pas celle ci qui se pose
moi je demande au gouvernement de
prendre ses responsabilités dd par
exemple les départements à financer nos
routes secondaires d'imposer aux
sociétés d'autoroutes une contribution
d'un milliard d'euros chaque année pour
financer les 450 mille kilomètres de
routes dans nos territoires pour
lesquels ni les communes ni les
départements non de moyens aux joueurs
pros
c'est une politique très longtemps au
sein d'infrastructures vous avez entendu
parler de l'actualité cet accident sur
le pont dont on en dira plus
effectivement à l'effondrement du pont
de mirepoix sur tarn
c'est en train de rouvrir tout de même
le débat est ce que pour vous il faut un
plan marshall pour remettre en état les
ponts en france la mission d'information
du sénat sur le sujet avait parlé de
25000 pont en mauvais état
le président de cette mission parle de
vrais dangerosité aujourd'hui en france
bien sûr nous devons tirer les
enseignements de ce drame terrible d'une
part de ce qui s'est passé en europe
bien sûr pour ça que tu soyons toujours
très prudent et attendant les résultats
de l'enquêté
il n'empêche en tant que parlementaire
est élu local je sais combien les
départements les communes ont de grandes
difficultés financières compte tenu du
désengagement de l'état pour entretenir
ce patrimoine et la proposition je fait
elle est encore très concrète vient de
l'évoquer
on sait que les sociétés d'autoroutes
ont cumulé sur le quand selon le
quotidien le monde 25 milliards d'euros
de bénéfices depuis leur privatisation
j'ai été hostile à l'époque et je pense
que nous avions et nous avions raison et
résoudre le gouvernement si vous avez
tort j'avais dit à l'époque que la
droite a eu tort mais oui par oui
parfois et parfois site vous avez eu
raison
jusqu'à maintenant vous savez ce qui
compte globalement enfin je suis très
fier d'être de droite est globalement
meilleure jésus servier rires et larmes
que nous portons il peut y avoir des
erreurs et celle ci à mon sens ce fut
une erreur lourde
je souhaite pour réparer cette erreur
que le gouvernement aujourd'hui en tout
cas c'est une proposition que je fais
demande aux sociétés d'autoroutes dont
les profits sont considérables de m
chaque année sur la table 1 milliards
d'euros qui seraient fléchés vers les
départements et les communes pour
améliorer l'entretien du réseau routier
secondaire
merci brigitte merci tam d'être venu sur
le tout d'auditions publiques comme tous
les lundis vous êtes fait alors rendez
vous merci beaucoup
guillaume pelletier maintenant on va
faire entrer sur ce plateau deux
parlementaires qu'ils vont vous
interrogez c'est aussi un bon moment
parce que ils ont aussi des questions
d'amélie
[Musique]
bonsoir jean rené cazeneuve vous êtes
député la république en marche du gers
président de la délégation aux
collectivités territoriales à
l'assemblée nationale et se fit taille
et polluant bonsoir vous êtes cnra
sénatrice générations ces mouvements de
benoît hamon apparenté ps du
val-de-marne
vous allez pouvoir interroger guillaume
pelletier peut-être puisqu'on parlait
tout à l'heure des hôpitaux on va
commencer peut-être par les hôpitaux et
sophie calle polluants c'est une
question là dessus notamment i les
services publics plus globalement mais
parce que c'est vrai que c'est toujours
compliqué quand on entend la droite
expliqué qu'il faut à la fois baisser
les dépenses publiques baisser les
impôts et puis qu'il faudra les finances
et financer les services publics alors
la chapelle si je vous entendais parler
du fait de mettre en place des
politiques de prévention très bien mais
ça a un coût je vous entends des aussi
parlé d'augmenter les médecins je vous
dirai peut-être d'ailleurs que c'est
peut-être aussi les infirmières et les
personnels et de soignants des hôpitaux
tout le dre j'ai préféré augmenter en
priorité parce que eux ne l'ont pas été
depuis fort longtemps alors que les
médecins sont très bien organisés pour
cela vis-à-vis de la sécurité sociale
donc s'ils voulaient y a quand même tout
le temps et on le voit moi je le vois
régulièrement aux débats dans les débats
de l'hémicycle du sénat où la droite
sans arrêt parle d'addiction à la
dépense publique donc j'irai que là il
faudrait quand même un petit peu nous
expliquer comment vous allez faire parce
que on voit bien qu'en fait tout cela
c'est un peu de poudre aux yeux quand
les gens se mobilisent pour demander de
l'argent pour les services publics
vous êtes derrière mais en réalité vous
souhaitez vous souhaitez je pense que
d'ailleurs j'ai lu dans quelques
quelques pages de votre livre que j'ai
regardé ce week end vous souhaitez quand
même baissé les dépenses publiques
réponse comment gérer cette seule chose
dans votre d'abord moi j'essaie de ne
pas opposer médecins infirmières et je
crois vous avez raison c'est vrai j'ai
parlé de ringer parler des personnels
hospitaliers et dans mon pool de santé
on a mis à égalité médecins et
infirmières et je sais combien dans nos
territoires ruraux heureusement qu'on a
des infirmes et d'infirmières qui sont
le dernier lien sur les questions de
santé je veux dans mon livre d'ailleurs
une revalorisation comme pour le
personnel des noës pad
si vous avez bien lu mon
bien sûr que j'ai c'est d'être un élu
responsable et je parle sur quelques
pages de la baisse des dépenses
publiques avec des propositions très
concrètes comme la lutte contre les
fraudes fiscales et sociales
mais si vous êtes honnêtes dans ce livre
comme dans les propositions que j'ai je
fais ce soir au nom de ma famille
politique
ce sont des propositions qui visent à
récompenser le travail et les forains
mais c'est pas là que 2,6 et comment
faisait ou pour faire plus de dépenses
publiques avec moins d'un pommeau et en
baissant je réunis en baissant les
impôts oui voilà j'aurai et sans faire
de dégâts puisque et sourire je vais
vous répondre à la retrait manquée
rentrons dans le détail on trie les
propositions que je fais d'abord c'est
un plan de baisse de 40 milliards
d'euros de dépenses publiques chaque
année comment 10 milliards de baisse sur
la lutte contre les fraudes fiscales et
sociales je propose par exemple de
priver de crédit d'impôt tout fraudeur
fiscal récidivistes ça me semble une
proposition concrète selon la cour des
comptes s'est probablement 10 à 15
milliards que nous pourrons venu
récupérer chaque année avec une
politique beaucoup plus ferme sur la
question
deuxièmement nous l'avons évoqué à
l'instant la réforme des retraites telle
que je la propose
c'est probablement environ 10 milliards
d'euros d'économies
chaque année donc il ya bien sûr des
économies à faire mais à l inverse d'une
autre droite ou d'une ancienne droite
c'est vrai ma génération
en tout cas tente d'imaginer dans le
prolongement de ce qui incarnèrent le
général de gaulle jacques chirac ou
nicolas sarkozy une droite sociale
populaire et écologique
ça peut vous surprendre je l'entends
dire ça s'est passé n'aurait pas tout
dépensé par sa fille ce sens mais c'est
que vous allez bien s'imaginer une
droite nouvelles voulait baisser les
moyens donnés aux retraites alors même
qu'il ya une augmentation du nombre de
sauts de retraités donc je vois pas
comment vous allez maintenir le pouvoir
d'achat des retraités
l'excusé voilà ce que vous m'avez bien
entendu je propose la suppression des
régimes spéciaux 6 milliards d'euros
chaque année
donc vous allez geslin baisser des
retraites pour beaucoup de gens non les
la suppression des régimes spéciaux
donc ça va signifier la baisse des
retraites pour ceux qui en bénéficient
des gens notamment qui ont des rêves
spéciaux parce qu'il travaille de nuit
parce qu'il travaillait pour tout nouvel
entrant
ils nous servent ces derniers fermant
légitime et je ne sais pas vous comment
vous faites dans votre territoire pour
expliquer à un compatriote qui vous a
deux compatriotes que vous avez en face
de vous quelqu'un qui est au public
quelqu'un qui est au privé quelqu'un qui
est dans un régime spécial quelqu'un qui
ne veut pas pourquoi depuis 40 ans nous
sommes incapables de créer une réforme
fondée sur l'idéal de
la justice c'est pas forcément de faire
comme si tout le monde avait le même
travail parce que les anges de
pénibilité d'horaires et ses joues
beaucoup
al c'est la raison pour laquelle
certains régimes spéciaux c'est juste il
a on aura je pense un point d'entente
dans la réforme que nous proposons est
question jacob et aurélien pradié
l'élément central que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure c'est la question de la
pénibilité bien sûr tous les métiers en
fait à identique mais on ne peut pas
avoir pour un salarié du privé
50 % des 25 meilleures années et pour un
fonctionnaire que j'étais puisque
j'étais professeur d'histoire géographie
comme premier métier
75% des six derniers mois il faut le
dire jean rené cazeneuve avec une
journée gaz devra parler de pouvoir
d'achat parce que vous parliez de ça
justement auprès des français et de la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation
oui ce qui s'est passé vieux métiers
bonjour bonjour s'est passé la semaine
dernière un événement assez important je
vous cause padiet d'y revenir
c'est la suppression la taxe
d'habitation enfin dernière fois que 80%
des français payer la taxe d'habitation
taxe d'habitation c'est que c'est un
impôt injuste ou aidants dont dans mon
gers natal dans ma préfecture est deux
fois plus importante qu'à paris je peux
vous dire qu'on a pas deux fois plus de
services à auch cas qu'à paris elle est
c'est une baisse de 12 des prélèvements
obligatoires
évidemment c'est un gain de pouvoir
d'achat je crois que c'est 2 732 euros
par part foyer donc c'est c'est un gain
de pouvoir d'achat très important cette
taxe d'habitation va être compensées
auprès des collectivités territoriales
et pourtant à ma grande surprise même si
c'est baisse des prélèvements
obligatoires
j'ai cru comprendre que longtemps votre
famille politique était pour la baisse
des taux des dépôts des prélèvements
obligatoires
vous avez voté contre la question est
assez simple si un jour les électeurs
rawdon de pouvoir est ce que vous allez
recréer la taxe d'habitation pour les
français vous savez très bien sur cette
question qui a deux problèmes que vous
devez connaître en tant que
parlementaire du gers comme chez moi
dans le loir et cher
est ce que la taxe d'habitation sera
vraiment compensé pour garantir la
liberté des communes ça fait pas que
votre gouvernement d'ailleurs vous
soutenez tous les autres depuis 40 ans
où il ya systématiquement nos images
vous savez très bien qu'il ya quelques
jours par exemple le gouvernement a
annoncé que la compensation de la
fameuse taxe professionnelle allait être
sacrément diminué 230 à 240 millions
d'euros et les communes comme les maires
ne sont pas idiots ils savent que pour
un ou deux
en ce sera garantie mais dans cinq ou
dix ans il y aura probablement un
problème ce qu'ont fait les
gouvernements alerte dont celui que vous
avez sous que j'ai voulu lancer
deuxièmement sur la fiscalité bien sûr
qu'il ya trop d'impôts et de taxes en
france et à ce titre la suppression de
la taxe d'habitation je le dis avec
beaucoup de clarté est une bonne idée
nous la rue mettriez mais en plein de
mai mais parce que tout est une question
d'équilibré dans le budget 2010 est de 8
20 qu'est ce qui se passe on nous
annonce 5 milliards d'euros de baisses
d'impôt sur le revenu mais on oublie de
nous dire qu'avec le gel de l'indexation
retraite prestations familiales ces
trois milliards d'euros de baisse du
pouvoir d'achat pour nos compatriotes
avec la question de la hausse des
cotisations agirc et arrco des retraites
c'est 2 milliards d'euros de baisses des
du pouvoir d'achat pour nos compatriotes
la baisse des apl c'est un milliard
d'euros de baisse du pouvoir d'achat
pour nos compatriotes
je veux juste que le gouvernement quel
qu'il soit soit honnête avec nos
compagnes aux questions de jean rené
cazeneuve
est-ce que vous remets trier en place
cette taxe d'habitation si vous vous
revenait au pouvoir
pour ma part je ne le pense pas je pense
que pour revenir mais c'est pas la ligne
de votre parti c'est nous allons
trancher voulait dit ses patrons juillet
prochain à l'occasion d'un congrès des
idées je pense que tout impôt supprimés
est une bonne idée dans notre pays
sauf que ce gouvernement vend du rêve ou
plutôt du vent puisque en face de la
signature d'un contrat d'un impôt pour
les lancer ainsi dans un dizaine des
dizaines et des dizaines c'est la raison
pour laquelle on a eu cette crise des
filets jaunes qui ont bien compris par
exemple avec la hausse de la csg combien
de retraités par exemple étaient les
premiers pénalisés se fait tailler
polluants oui aussi interrogé guillaume
pelletier sur le chômage les allocations
chômage notamment
écoutez oui parce que on entend beaucoup
beaucoup de choses se dire sur sur
finalement l'assistanat c'est un de vos
grand credo l'assistanat et vous
d'ailleurs vous dit tout à l'heure vous
défendez 70% des français les 30 autres
pourcents visiblement ne valent pas que
vous les défendez
moi je pense qu'il faut les défendre
aussi et notamment lorsqu'ils sont
victimes d'un système extrêmement
puissant qui ce qui s'abat contre eux
est celui de la précarité la
précarisation du travail et aussi de la
raréfaction du travail or ce que ce que
ce que je vois aussi dans vos propos
c'est le fait que vous dites il faut
remettre les gens au travail etc
mais on entend tout le temps parler
et des fameuses emplois non pourvus ils
sont au nombre de 300 milles il y a cinq
millions cinq cent mille personnes
inscrites à pôle emploi sans parler de
celles qui ne sont pas inscrits qui ont
je dirais une voie plus l'utilité
puisque pôle emploi ne les reçoit pas
puisqu'il n'y a pas assez d'agents c'est
dur à accepter
donc ma question est comment vous faites
pour dire il faut c'est les gens qui
travaillent mais il y en a beaucoup en
fait ils ne trouvent pas de travail
donc vous êtes là à dire ce sont des
assistés comme moi comment vous faites
parce que faire rentrer cinq millions
500 mille dans trois cent mille emplois
non pourvus ça me semble un petit peu
difficile
il trouvera dans vos propos un peu
caricaturaux franchement à ce que
j'essaie d'avoir un débat apaisé
moi je veux que réconcilier tous les
français et la corde est tout entière
mais ma conviction en tout cas je vois
vous ne la partagent et pas c'est que la
politique du gouvernement ne s'adresse
qu'aux premiers de cordée et que les
politiques publiques depuis très
longtemps ont particulièrement
accompagner les dernier de cordée
laissant sur le bord de la route
70% des français qui se sentent
aujourd'hui dépossédés bien sûr je les
ai vécus si vous avez bien lu de mon
livre
familialement à travers le chômage de
mon père je sais pertinemment ce que
veut dire cet idéal de justice dans
notre pays à travers la solidarité
nationale modèle exemplaire que nous
devons défendre
je crois à ce modèle de solidarité je
crois qu'il est nécessaire et
indispensable d'accompagner ceux qui
n'ont rien et qui se bat contre contre
un civil à l'honneur il n'empêche c'est
entendu il n'empêche la réponse que moi
j'apporte qui n'est pas celle
effectivement qui fut porté ces quarante
dernières années est la suivante je
considère que le grand mal français
legrand la grande difficulté pour nos
entreprises pour qu'elles puissent
recruter c'est que les salaires sont
trop bas est temps que nous
n'augmenterons pas les salaires nous ne
donnerons pas envie à ceux qui
travaillent de continuer à travailler à
ceux qui ont travaillé comme les
retraités d'être récompensé après une
dure vie de labeur et nous ne donnerons
pas envie à ceux qui sont aujourd'hui
bénéficiaire d'un revenu d'assistance de
passer au travail vous savez je reçois
chaque semaine j'ai un zoo parc le
zooparc de beauval dans la
circonscription avec les fameux panda
il ya une baisse de la tva toute
l'équipe a créé 120 nouveaux contrats il
est encore 80 contre 1 disponible malgré
un millier d'emplois de chômeurs dans ce
territoire pourquoi toutes les personnes
que
soit me disent la même chose monsieur le
député on n'acceptera pas ce travail
d'abord parce qu'il n'est pas assez
payés et parce que aujourd'hui en
cumulant les revenus de l'assistance
franchement l'intérêt d'aller travailler
est faible et bien c'est un électrochoc
que je veux créer en disant à tous les
français si vous allez travailler
vous serez bien mieux récompensé que
nous l'avons été jusqu'à maintenant jean
rené cazeneuve je me tourne vers vous
parce que il y à un autre sujet dans
l'air du temps en ce moment c'est une
proposition qui vient de vous rend ce
sont les questions autour des listes
communautariste pour les élections
municipales et ça ça vous interpelle et
ça vous suggère une question liée au
métier
oui on est on est à la veille du congrès
des maires qui est un événement
extrêmement important que vous l'avez
dit tout à l'heure je suis d'accord et
vous le maire c'est le pilier de la
république on avait absolument besoin le
conforter là on parle d'un seul coup
d'aunis communautaire et je voudrais
comprendre parce que la loi aujourd'hui
permet d'éviter je pourrais tu es dans
une campagne électorale tous les propos
homophobes sinophobe la loi aussi
condamné les propos qui ne
respecteraient pas les valeurs de la
république
la loi permet aujourd'hui de condamner
des élus qui ne respecteraient pas la
laïcité par exemple dans l'exercice de
leur mandat donc elle a fait un certain
nombre de choses deuxième remarque c'est
que comment on identifie une liste
communautaire mais vous l'aimeriez
toutes les communautés qui existent en
france vous est mise bien que personne
ne va se déclarer en disant écoutez moi
je suis une ligne commune ariste et je
vais et je vais évidemment ne pas
respecter la laïcité en france
est ce que ça veut dire qu'il faut faire
un contrôle préalable des candidats on
met le doigt dans quelque chose qui me
paraît d'un point de vue républicain
extrêmement difficile alors ma question
elle est simple est-ce que pour quelque
chose qui n'est à mon avis absolument
pas applicable et je ne suis pas naïf du
tout sur ces questions là est-ce que
vous n'êtes pas en train d'agiter le
chiffon rouge de
du communautarisme et puis comment des
finances se sont dits reviens j'ai je
vais trouve être très précis vous savez
si bruno retailleau gérard larcher
xavier bertrand françois baroin mois et
quelques autres nous faisons cette
proposition c'est dans un esprit
responsable parce que nous sommes
lucides sur l'un des grands enjeux de
notre temps que même olivier faur
d'ailleurs le nouveau premier secrétaire
du parti socialiste et vox matin dans
les colonnes d'un quotidien la laïcité
dans notre pays est menacé et notre
adversaire je le dis dans la sérénité
mais avec autorité
oui c'est l'islam politique donc sur
internet islamistes je pose ce premier
brevet et j'apporte la réponse parce que
bien sûr que le communautarisme de
sécession qui nous menacent aujourd'hui
est plutôt lié à l'islam politique mais
nous voulons combattre tous les
communautarismes comme aux autres mais
comme les autres mais les kills ou
comment il peut y avoir des entités
communautaires de dérives sectaires vous
savez que c'est pas simplement sur le
plan religieux
la proposition régionalistes la
proposition la proposition que nous
faisons est la suivante c'est de dire
pourquoi ne pas demander à chaque
candidat à une élection et à chaque
parti politique de s'engager autour
d'une charte de la laïcité fondée sur
trois piliers la reconnaissance de la
liberté de culte et de conscience dans
notre pays c'est à dire que chacun a le
droit de pratiquer ou de ne pas
pratiquer une religion
deuxièmement la reconnaissance absolue
de l'égalité entre les hommes et les
femmes principe sacrément attaqué dans
sa tombe de nos territoires et de nos
quartiers ou de nos hôpitaux
troisièmement redire ce principe
d'évidence que nous partageons tous les
lois de la république sont au dessus de
toutes les convictions religieuses ma
conviction notre conviction c'est qu'à
travers cette charte de la laïcité nous
pourrions envoyer un signal à nos
compatriotes
nous sommes lucides sur le problème et
si jamais une fois responsabilité ou
élus une formation ou un candidat ne
respectez pas à ces critères
on pourrait suspendre le financement du
parti politique en question
c'est possible dans la loi comme vous
l'avez dit ou de suspendre l'élu en
question vous savez que la république
peut dans des cas exceptionnels
suspendre un élu dans l'exercice de ses
mandats
j'ai une question parce que
je ne peux aussi les républicains n'est
pas trop pour l'égalité femmes hommes
puisque vous présenter toujours beaucoup
plus de candidats hommes
ok vous savez si vous avez bien regardé
la nouvelle équipe dirigeante
christelle manga président de la région
pays de la loire sophie gaugain première
vice-présidente citez-moi la région
c'est d'emmener en avait pas emilie
bonnivard valérie beauvais et tant
d'autres je suis pas suivre dans vos
pratiques
aujourd'hui vous avez 10 et bien je
pense que j'avais pas vu le moindre
l'immédiat le garder sur l'égalité
salariale hommes femmes sur l'égalité
hommes femmes jeunes important est que
nous voulons garder jour aux jeux je
l'interrogeais je suis assez d'accord
avec ce que vous dites mais je crois que
tout ce que vous dites est possible
aujourd'hui la loi permet de lutter
contre ces dérives je suis pas certain
qu'il faille ajouter quelque chose alors
peut-être faut faire une déclaration de
bonne conduite c'est peut-être une
charte de bonne conduite
mais il pourrait exonérer public
peut-être peut-être un discours du
président à peu près bien pour annoncer
que sur ces critères nous ne
tergiversons plus mais nous sommes un
grand pays et nous sommes tous
intransigeant par avance à moi je vous
dire que moi je préfère le combat des
idées d'accord à cette sorte de 2,2 de
censure qui aurait lieu en amont de la
constitution des listes
je pense que on est pas du tout là où il
faut pour notre république qui répondait
non mais j'entends la moins 50 crawl a
posteriori moi je mais si on va empêcher
les listes il faut bien en amont les
empêcher donc ça veut dire qu'il
faudrait faire un contrôle donc vous
laissez donc vous touchez le litchi pas
léger parce qu'il va falloir faire il va
falloir passer un test
donc oui c'est vrai que c'est flou il
faut nommer sur la mise en pratique ses
traits sur la mise en pratique vous
savez comment ça se passe on appelle
république quand on veut être candidat
on va déclarer sa candidature en
préfecture où il apporte un certains
nombre de renseignements veille du
ferret ville
il suffirait d'y ajouter la charte de la
laïcité signée par les candidats c'est
un engagement qui permettrait de manille
d'appât par les partis politiques par
chaque candidat et ça permettrait à la
justice de manière immédiate en cas de
non-respect de sanctionner ou de
suspendre le candidat on va arrêter de
se raconter des histoires ça fait des
décennies que nous sommes naïfs et lâche
sur le sujet nous ouvrons ce qui se
passe dans nos hôpitaux quand des hommes
refus d'être auscultés par des femmes et
des femmes par des hommes
nous mesurons ce qui se passe dans nos
écoles de la république lorsque des
professeurs n'arrive plus enseigner la
shoah à nos élèves nous mesurons les
attentats nous mesurons
le communautarisme rampant nous mesurons
le fait que des femmes depuis ce qu
rentrer dans des brasseries ou des
restaurants dans des quartiers
populaires parce que ce sont des femmes
ces dérives sont inacceptables et le
rôle d'un élu de la république en tout
cas de ma génération c'est de dire que
l'islam politique et notre adversaire et
que la république est aujourd'hui testé
ne doit pas céder se fait tailler polian
vouliez évoqué un autre enjeu du moment
évidemment c'est l'environnement
l'écologie principalement parce que
c'est l'aspect manquant semble-t-il
quand vous avez oui et puis vint je vois
un petit peu les déclarations monsieur
pelletier fait beaucoup de social dont
du social à la sauce libérale c'est à
dire méritocratie voilà un nom mais
chacun moi j'ai fait mon analyse sur
votre sur vos propositions et c'est vrai
que c'est quand même toujours beaucoup
on vous donne le minimum et puis après
débrouillez-vous dans la grande
compétition mais je pense effectivement
que sur les questions environnementales
je ne le comprends pas ce que j'ai
l'impression quand même que vous mesurez
pas les défis qui sont face à nous et
les propositions vous faites sur en deçà
et donc je vous propose de nous en dire
plus bien sûr alors franchement j'y
reviens avec beaucoup de
un petit clin d'oeil je vais vous donner
mon livre et vous le dédicacer parce que
vous l'avez pas lu il y a plusieurs
pages sur l'écologie et je vais un peu
peuvent non mais sur l'éthologie vous
pouvez pas dire qu'on n'en parle pas que
j'étais exclue on a franchement sortie
de georges pompidou à nicolas sarkozy du
premier ministère de l'environnement au
grenelle de l'environnement
ma famille politique dès aujourd'hui on
peut pas dire vous n'avez rien fait non
non c'est pas directement
c'est du concret deux propositions
concrètes je pense que c'est rare de
faire autant de propositions en une
heure
du concret je vous propose deux choses
moi je propose d'abord un tribunal
climatique international pour juger les
multinationales du sol ventes au niveau
international et en amazonie ou dans
l'absolu une telle érosion est d'accord
avec vous voyez on a vibré création le
dessus et nous avons proposé
effectivement qu'on a des propos vifs
est de mettre en place d'éco side au
niveau du hamas international et
européen comme au congo deuxième poumon
vert de notre planète
il y à des dérives absolument
inacceptable et c'est ce que je reproche
au gouvernement actuel c'est de s'en
prendre fiscalement aux petits aux
citoyens et des très lâche avec ceux qui
polluent c'est-à-dire quelques détails
multinationales qui ne respectent rien
des accords de mandarine et de 10 hôtels
mais tout
entre autres vous désire céder pour que
je vous dise ah oui j l'huile de palme
c'est quand même les républicains qui
ont voté pour que l'huile de palme soit
toujours dans les carburants
c'est pas mon cas la nouvelle génération
à droite est en train de manière très
concrète avec cette proposition et je
veux en faire une seconde tout de suite
d'incarner une écologie sociale c'est à
dire pas une écologie contradictoire
avec le pouvoir d'achat une équ ans une
écologie qui se réconcilie avec le
pouvoir d'achat comment je fais deux
propositions je propose la gratuité de
la carte grise pour tous les véhicules
propres
comme vient de le faire xavier bertand
dans sa région et je propose la tva 0%
pour toute vente d'un produit frais par
un agriculteur à un consommateur
ça c'est du concret ça c'est de
l'écologie c'est dans mon livre est
aujourd'hui fière d'euros chaque année
ça se cumulent un pour que nous
puissions uniquement répondre à nos
engagements pris à paris en a comme 21
donc je suis bien d'accord très bien la
carte grise parfait enfin là c'est un
autre niveau que se joue la question sur
l'ecosite très bien mais entre les deux
il ya quand même une capacité de notre
pays qui doit investir massivement
et encore une fois j'y reviens avec vos
baisses d'impôts avec vos baisses de
dépenses publiques
voilà et vos propositions la notion par
monsieur à la mesure du problème et
s'est excusé moi ah bah si vous pensez
que créer un tribunal climatique
international gratuité de la carte grise
tva à zéro pour tous les jeux cultes
heures en cercle proximité et tout le
reste vous lirez le reste dans le livre
ce sont des propositions extrêmement
concrètes qui parle à nos concitoyens et
qui nous permettront de tourner le dos à
de l'écologie punitive et d'incarner une
écologie sociale qui valorise et
comportements vertueux c'est l'enjeu le
défi de ma génération parlais tout à
l'heure du congrès de l'association des
maires de france parce que c'est en ce
moment et jean rené cazeneuve vous ça
vous intéresse ce congrès parce que vous
vous dites bon derrière il ya peut-être
quand même une espèce de manip politique
c'est ça oui alors je skie mais
peut-être mal à l'aise c'est que
contrairement à ce que vous avez dit
tout à l'heure si je peux me permettre
est il que présent la public ne tenait
pas ses engagements c'est bien quelque
chose qui la fait vis-à-vis des
collectivités des collectivités
territoriales c'est qu'il a tenu ses
engagements
donc on a maintenu les dotations
financières alors qu'elles avaient
fortement baissé
auparavant on a arrêté ce bricolage
institutionnel la loi notamment matin
etc
on a stabilisé l'organisation
territoriale
on a même avec la loi engagement et
proximité qui est discuté en ce moment à
l'assemblée nationale remis de mer au
centre de l'intercommunalité donc on
fait beaucoup de choses et c'est normal
parce que les maires sont des éléments
très importants dans notre république
et bien pourtant il ya une style it est
quasi systématique des associations
alors de certaines associations et en
fait quand on creuse deux présidents de
certaines associations c'est là que je
suis un peu gêné ses sauts deluxe
connais je suis un petit peu gêné et je
me demande
et quand je vois les déclarations
politiques et des écuries
présidentielles qui sont quelque part en
train de se mettre en place
je me dis est ce qu a pas un malaise là
et est ce qu'il faudrait pas que les
associations d'élus joue le rôle
d'associé sont élus à la veille du
congrès et ne viennent pas des écuries
présidentielles vous une soirée commune
peut-être alors françois baroin est
vraiment non mais entre autres
c'est quand même c'est pas moi ce sont
les observateurs qui est françois marque
a toujours été plutôt dur avec vous il
ya quelques années et vous a traité un
peu de tous les noms de subordonner
debuisson de faire de la télé réalité
etc etc
bon je suis aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est
acceptable quand on doit tous se réunir
dans un réflexe républicain
tous se réunir derrière nos mères que
d'utiliser ça comme tribune politique
moi je m'entends très bien avec françois
baroin dominique bussereau renaud
muselier hervé morin qui a
instrumentalisé mépriser les maires de
notre nation ces dernières années à
travers une polémique
vous vous en souvenez balances ton mer
extrêmement maladroite en tout cas un
certain nombre de membres du
gouvernement et le prêt dans la
république ont été n'ont pas été au
rendez vous
de la tante considérable de nos élus
locaux et il est légitime que des
présidents démocratiquement élus
françois baroin et le président choisi
par les maires de france absolument
dominique bussereau l'est par les
présidents des départements de france
hervé maurey et renaud muselier le sont
par les présidents des régions de france
oui la vérité c'est que la france des
territoires et des provinces elle
appartient aujourd'hui à la droite
républicaine parce que nos concitoyens
voit bien qu'entre le maquereau nisme
qui prône une forme de dérégulation de
capitalisme financier et de mépris des
territoires d'une part c'est faux et le
populisme des extrêmes nous essayons
d'inventer et d'imaginer un chemin de
crête et 3 certes mais qui garantit
l'unité de la république et les
représentants des territoires j'en ai
caisses de l'association des maires de
france n'est pas une filiale des
républicains mais en quoi c'est ce qu'il
disait à peu près ce que françois baroin
ont fait une tribune perdre mais ne
l'est pas et il est dans une
d'opposition et magnat systématique
c'est dommage on est dans une classe
alors moi j'ai une position quasi
systématique et ça n'est pas le cas de
l'association des communautés france ça
n'est pas le cas de l'association france
urbaine qui représente les métropoles
etc
donc il ya bien quelques associations
aujourd'hui ils se sont focalisés et qui
sont dans un plus petit et qui ont d'une
certaine manière tu qu'ils sont dans une
phase un refus quasi systématique je
pense que c'est dommage parce que l on a
un rôle extrêmement d'entre eux achètent
beaucoup de respect pour françois baroin
est donc usb je pense qu'elles doivent
être et à la veille du congrès des
maires mon message est un message
d'espoir battons-nous ensemble pour les
élus pour les territoires mais n'en
faisons pas une question passé il ya un
an lorsque les gilets jaunes manifesté
par centaines de milliers et que le
président de la république était aux
abois
gérard larcher président du sénat
françois baroin président des maires de
france et tant d'autres et nous avec eux
nous avons été des élus responsables
pour dire au président la république
il est temps de nous entendre le prix
depuis peut pas demander en permanence à
la veille des congrès des maires aux
associations et zélie d'être calme lui
qui est incapable de faire des
propositions concrètes au service de nos
territoires
si le président est capable de mettre
sur la table les propositions comme nous
les avons évolué tout à l'heure très
bien nous serons à ses côtés pierre est
temps qu'il entende la colère des élus
la réponse on l'aura demain à l'issue du
discours du président de la république
devant le congrès de l'association des
maires de france et on verra tout ça
merci jean rené cazeneuve merci sophy
taillé et poli ondes est revenue sur ce
plateau on va entamer maintenant la
dernière partie de cette émission
auditions publiques et c'est yves
thréard du figaro qui nous rejoignent
nous a beaucoup écouté vous surtout un
en détail bonjour yves avoue débris
filles bronzant francis bonjour
guillaume pelletier alors je vous ai
écouté avec beaucoup d'attention et
alors le propos liminaire que vous avez
eue sur président de la république vous
avez dit j'aimerais bien qu'ils fassent
l'union avec lui même j'ai envie de dire
mais j'espère que vous allez faire
l'union avec votre camp parce que quand
on vous écoute on se dit que bien vous
avez changé de camp finalement est ce
que vous êtes toujours de droite vous
êtes contre la privatisation d'aéroports
de paris sont le savez vous êtes pour
l'établissement d'un tribunal
international écologique mais ça c'est
du vocabulaire qui appartient à jean luc
mélenchon génère françois ruffin je sais
pas vous êtes pour le rachat de la dette
des hôpitaux vous baroin pour taxer les
autoroutes où vous êtes pour augmenter
le celui qui est augmentée en tous les
cas les salaires parce que vous trouvez
que les salaires sont trop bas vous êtes
pour une tva à taux zéro pour les
produits frais mais on se dit le
discours de la droite il ya quelques
années qui est un discours raisonnable
en disant on va faire baisser les
déficits on va résorber la dette est
avec vous la dette elle explose alors on
se demande comment vous allez faire
j'ai une question parce que vous avez
oublié un élément de votre programme qui
vous tient à coeur de votre programme
personnel pas de programme des
républicains
le rétablissement de l'impôt sur la
fortune
c'est ce que vous préconisez non c'est
yves thréard vous êtes un journaliste
honnête je vais rejoindre en deux temps
à votre diatribe un peu caricatural si
vous me permettez vous avez bien écouté
pendant cette émission j'ai parlé d'une
baisse de 40 milliards des dépenses
publiques chaque année oui nos
règlements en faisant la chasse aux abus
pas du tout monde où j'ai expliqué sur
les fraudes sociales et fiscales
oui sur la réforme des retraites sur une
allocation sociale unique tant de
propositions très concrètes
donc ça c'est de vote
mais tout ce que je sauve votre réforme
des retraites je perds gt a vu beaucoup
de différence avec la réforme actuelle
vous perdez spéciaux c'est ce qui veut
bien les caricatures - ma droite notre
droit avec christian jacob
avec leurs alliés à pradines avec
françois baroin avec xavier bertrand
avec very pécresse oui c'est une droite
qui s'inscrit dans la filiation du
général de gaulle le jacques chirac
l'impossible georges pompidou j'y
reviens de nicolas sarkozy et de tant
d'autres
c'est une droite qui récompense la
valeur du travail c'est pas une droite
froides statistiques impôts sur inocule
je vous raconte la sueur suivante c'est
pas du tout leur établissement le dff
je propose la suppression de l'ifi c'est
à dire de l'impôt qui pèse sur les
propriétaires et sur les investisseurs
dans les pme françaises ça c'est une
mesure courageuse et par contre oui je
propose le rétablissement d'un impôt sur
les spéculateurs c'est toujours est
redevenu l'exact inverse des manuels
macron qui a supprimé l'impôt pour les
spéculateurs et qui l'a maintenu ou
augmenté pour les propriétaires et les
investisseurs la droite que nous
défendons et que nous incarnons oui ça
n'est pas la droite de l'argent et de la
finance c'est la droite du travail de
l'effort du mérite des classes moyennes
des artisans des commerçants des
entrepreneurs et la droite de la france
quand on vigilance yeux est majoritaire
on avait des doutes sur votre
appartenance à droite ça vous met très
en colère mais non mais parce que parce
que je vous on se connaît depuis
longtemps istréens et ça fait longtemps
que vous m'interviewer et je pense que
si vous aviez pris le temps de lire mon
livre de manière intégrale vous auriez
vu combien ces propositions sont
équilibrés des missons peu d'accord on
peut sortir quelques propositions hors
contrôle
c'est la vision buzek a été là la vision
que nous avons ensemble avec christian
jacob celle équilibre où il ya l'esprit
d'entreprise
oui à l'initiative individuelle mais oui
à la régulation d'un cabinet oui un anti
terroristes et les milices et la
victoire aux municipales j'imagine il ya
beaucoup de villes à enjeu pour vous aux
républicains nous sommes en train de les
porter avec christian jacob
qu'est ce qui s'est passé à nice il y a
6 mois vous m'interrogez à juste titre
en disant voilà les républicains ça
marche pas vous êtes divisés nous sommes
parvenus grâce à eric ciotti grâce à
christian estrosi avec christian jacob à
mettre notre famille en ordre les
accords et services qu'avez vous propose
eric ciotti pour qui se renie
beaucoup de travail beaucoup ce drame
est comme ça non mais justice est
retirée comme ça pour la bonne cause
mais vous savez qu'il ya quelque chose
qui nous transcende nous tous c'est
l'intérêt général vous savez que j'avais
toujours j'avais été désigné mois tête
de liste aux élections régionales il ya
trois ans et au dernier moment on me dit
dans la cale du cadre d'un accord avec
les centristes
je suis numéro deux alors je me suis pas
rouler par terre il ya quelque chose qui
nous dépasse c'est l'intérêt général de
notre famille politique
eric ciotti l'a bien compris c'est
christian estrosi qui sera notre
candidat à nice à paris nous avons avec
rachid dali une candidate enracinée qui
défend justement les classes de moyenne
section questions sur nice par exemple
s'il ya un candidat s'il n'y a pas de
candidat de la république en manche est
ce que vous accepteriez que la
république en marche soutiennent
monsieur estrosi qui est toujours aux
républicains tout comme peut-être à
toulouse
monsieur jean luc moudenc pourrait être
soutenu par la république en extraire
vous connaissez la préside depuis
combien de temps
depuis très très longtemps peut-être
plus que geek certainement qu'elle est
quel est le jeu dans marche en marche
n'a pas d'élus locaux en marche n'a pas
d'enracinement wheeler gardot est donc
en marche ce que vous faites une
politique de coucou essayant à nice à
toulouse ou ailleurs de soutenir des
élus qui sont chez nous ça me gênerait
ou pas mais franchement avec christian
jacob ça ne nous intéresse pas on s'en
contrefiche de l'ariana nom des gens lui
signifiait toulouse il est soutenu par
la tendance
soyons précis jean luc moudenc c'est un
maire de notre famille politique il a
toujours été loyal à notre famille
politique il est investi par les
républicains il en a trop misé sur sa
liste il aura alors 40 pouvons donc ça
s'est passé pas vrai vous avez que
j'étais maire d'une commune
on voit que vous avez jamais été
candidat aux élections musique el paso
ce qui est tout à fait jouable ça pour
vous cette année vous savez ce qui se
passe une élection municipale
comment constituer une liste vous croyez
que c'est les options partisane qui
l'emportent sur les options d'intérêt du
territoire loeb sur ma liste en 2014 et
chacun connaît mes convictions
enraciné de droite vous croyez que
j'avais que des adhérents des
républicains gema répond non donc nous
avons bâti bhl nous soutenons les têtes
de liste les républicains et si en
marche veut s'amuser à faire une
politique de coucou pour masquer son
incapacité à être présent sur le terrain
vous êtes sans problème argument c'est
pas le nôtre d'accord alors
une ville une ville c'est toujours très
compliqué vous la connaissez bien
marseille marseille monsieur gaudin se
retire jean claude gaudin se retire et
vous avez deux candidats un qui est
soutenu par monsieur gaudin madame
martine vassal est en phase ii et bruno
gilles qui est qui veut pas se retirer
comment vous allez trancher la question
dans le respect mutuel
comme on a réussi à le faire à nice nous
ne prétendons pas avec christian jacob
est en capacité de le réussir à
marseille c'est le défi des 15 prochains
jours
nous nous sommes rencontrés nous avons
demandé aux deux candidats de bien
réfléchir à l'obligation qui est la
nôtre au nom de la colère des français
de l'arrogance du maquereau nisme de
notre responsabilité à incarner une
autre voie un autre chemin pour
permettre aux français de ne pas revivre
le duel mortifère macron le pen
nous leur avons demandé à chacun de
faire un effort et conquis son conjoint
ils ont quinze jours pour se mettre
d'accord ça se passe pas comme ça vous
savez donne ce que vous avez dit on
s'est fixé nous la cop 15 jours on se
revoit donc un caveau référence bruno
genou maintenant que sa salle je suis
numéro deux du parti selon lui justement
non ben justement quand on est
responsable dans une famille politique
on est garant de l'unité de la famille
tant que la décision n'est pas prise
aujourd'hui je demande à martine vassal
et à bruno gilles de tout faire en
respectant et en comprenant les enjeux
et les ambitions de chacun de trouver
une solution
marseille vous peut-être pas de toute
façon ou à marseille ou à paris nous
discutons tous les jours question cour
qui n'est pas vraiment une question
qu'on pourrait se poser
s'il y avait
la nécessité de faire un front
républicain pour faire barrage à un
candidat du rassemblement national
est-ce que vous iriez dans ce front
républicain je ne suis ni madame irma ni
un fan de la politique fiction et je me
méfie des questions politiques et
médiatiques qui vise à faire de l'
exception la règle ça fait 20 ans qu'on
nous explique que le front national va
prendre des centaines de communes des
dizaines de région et de département à
10 heures salle armingué ça n'arrive
jamais nous ne voulons pas du maquereau
nisme nous ne voulons pas de l'extrême
droite et nous voulons dire aux 72 % de
français à la une de votre quotidien le
figaro il ya quelques jours il existe un
autre chemin
vous n'aurez pas à revivre macron le pen
en 2022
ce chemin vous aussi les fonds des
restaurants trop autour de la famille
des républicains c'est de notre alliance
de la droite et du centre ont sans doute
des élections régionales de 1998 qui ont
fait beaucoup de mal à la droite et de
2015 voilà où nous avait dit que mad à
nos questions tout le monde reste une
question est une réponse à françois
baroin candidat pour la présidentielle
de 2002 c'est pas à moi de répondre
françois baroin est un immense talent
notre famille politique comme avait
bertrand d'ailleurs étendent au début
dans votre famille mais qui il revient
progressivement de ses proches aux
figues gauguin julien dive ont rejoint
l'équipe dirigeante françois baron est
revenu dans la famille christian estrosi
eric ciotti se sont mis d'accord oui
avec christian jacob nous sommes au
travail pour mettre de l'or avec d'être
assemblés et préparer et présenter des
idées nouvelles
prado famille politique les idées les
idées avant les héroïnes merci merci
guillaume pepy est devenu maire jean
auditions publiques n'oubliez pas que
vous pouvez retrouver cette émission
surveillée en blagues sur les comptes
twitter de lcp public sénat
bonne semaine merci et à lundi prochain
[Musique]